and luis castillo will
head out to the mound and arguably the
biggest game of his
career first and second two outs
right-handed hitting casting hero that's
a fair ball
and cassalli will tag out here
single walk no problem brandon woodruff
making career start number six
appearance number eight
against the reds he's currently three
and two including a win he beat castillo
early this year
two two on akiyama here comes brandon
woodruff to the plate
and he struck him out looking fast ball
at the knees gets what he wants from
omar narvaez the 2-2 pitch and
at 99 right at the knees strike three
called
back-to-back case for woodruff second
and third with one out
and you've got a piece and into the mid
hanging on is narvaez that is a big
strikeout for woodruff
two away in the second
[Applause]
smash and vogelback is there
oh big man doing some work again at
first base with a second straight game
and woodruff gets out of trouble
[Applause]
that is good morning good afternoon and
good night to garcia
and that is for castillo
19th three pitch strikeout this season
and now the 2-2 pitch
see ya back-to-back strikeouts for
castillo
tune two on shogo akiyama
and a half swing and a miss that was a
very awkward looking swing from akiyama
notch up another strikeout for brandon
woodruff that's number four
akiyama was looking for that pitch to be
away and it was in under his hands
and he wanted no part of that
two and two on castellanos see where
they go here
the pitch struck him out with a fastball
in the outside corner
two more strikeouts in the third inning
for brandon woodruff give him
five in the first three here's the
one-two pitch
swing and a miss and down on strikes
ryan braun luis castillo
facing this brewers order a second time
has struck out each of the first three
castillo back in there payoff pitch
swing gonna miss struck him out that
time he was able to
get the change up where he wanted it in
off the plate hira swings through it
castillo with four punch out through the
first four
inning zerko will lead things off for
milwaukee here in the fifth inning
and here's a drive hit back into deep
left field
and the brewers are on the board
a blast off the bat of jed jericho and
it's one to nothing
he has been very productive since he's
been getting a lot of playing time
tonight at third base
big power for jed jerko
and the brewers strike first using the
long ball
all right it's up to suarez here
costiano's on third base two outs
now the one two in the air
left center field that bad boy is
gone
[Applause]
hey eugeo suarez one swing of the bat
and the reds take the lead
now that's a great call he finally got
the fastball that he was looking for
suarez did anyway
and woodruff will not face another
batter they're celebrating in the reds
bullpen they're celebrating in the
dugout
[Applause]
two outs here in the top of the seventh
inning runners at
second and third for the brewers and a
big
big out if garrett can pull this rabbit
out of the hat
the pinch ground ball headed to suarez
at third he will backhand he will throw
end time devoto and the reds
avoid the issue here against
the brewers in the seventh and drew
rasmussen
is on the mound for the brewers he'll
face curt casalli
and the air off the bat of curt casalli
and out of here
oh that's a large run
number six for curt
well he greets a brand new pitcher drew
rasmussen with a
long shot off a 96 mile an hour fastball
two out batters mike muzakis looking
ahead to the ninth for the brewers
the pitch and mustache drives one deep
right field peterson back at the wall
gone into the sherman bears
glove over the right field fence a
three-run
home run for mike moustakis
the reds have blown it open it's 6-1
sitting on fastball he got fastball it
was elevated just enough over the
outside
corner the 2-2
peterson a long drive deep right field
and no
doubter for jase peterson
and it's a six to two ball game make it
six to three
a two run shot off the bat of jase
peterson yeah good for him boy he put a
charge into that
goodness
a couple of hits a home run in this
inning
in the air to left akiyama under it
and that'll do it the reds take game one
of this crucial three-game set
against the brewers